Wayne Gretzky — arguably the greatest
hockey player of all time — said he didn't
skate to the puck, but to where the puck
was going. Ice hockey is a fluid,
unpredictable game. He couldn't know how
the game would develop, so he practiced his
skating and his stick handling. Today's
labor market is like that. Every month,
millions of jobs are created and
eliminated. Technology is changing how
jobs are done at an even faster pace. The
skills of today can be obsolete tomorrow.
What's a human to do? Like Gretzky we
should all focus on the basics. First is
mastery of reading, writing, and math.
Second: technological literacy. We don't
all need to be coders, but we have to be
able to understand and use data and
software. Third, we need to develop our
most human qualities: creativity,
intuition, and empathy. Don't fight the machines — transcend them. A dynamic, growing
economy creates new opportunities every
day, but just like Gretzky, we have to
have the skills to take advantage of
them and to skate to where the puck is going.
What do you think makes for career
success? Let us know in our poll. Also, let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.